j'ai cherché ces de nucléaire civil en
amérique de schifflange en choeur les
plus différents
dans ce sujet d'armes et sur le carbone
et le chercher les championnats jours
d'un moment il est beaucoup imputé ces
gens veulent manger c'est un titre qui
était le qui a accroché un autre et vous
à désirer roxane et du bien que vous
présentiez et non pas
l'autonomie on sera tous se scinde avons
l'honneur de recevoir monsieur jean marc
jancovici spécialiste de l'énergie et du
climat
diplômé de l'école polytechnique ainsi
que de l'école nationale supérieure des
télécommunications de paris
il est l'auteur principal ce bilan
carbone pour le compte de l'ademe et
travaille aujourd'hui avec alain
grandjean sur le développement de
carbone 4 cabinets de conseil technique
dans le domaine de la transition
énergétique en parallèle monsieur
jancovici mais le nombre important
d'activités cofondateur des entretiens
énergie climat membre du conseil
scientifique de la fondation nicolas
hulot membre associé de l'académie
royale de belgique et du comité des
experts du débat sur la transition
énergétique et plein d'autres c'est un
bébé c'est impressionnant parmi les
actions les plus importants ce monsieur
l'embolie ci est enseignant à vinh
paristech et fondateur du chief project
site international de réflexion sur les
politiques de transition énergétique
il est l'auteur de cet ouvrage mon
certains traduit dans une dizaine de
langues et a mené plus de 600
conférences et formations dans plus de
10 pays qu il était chroniqueur sur
france info au 20 heures de tf1 est
aujourd'hui dans le journal les échos
il est l'auteur site internet de sites
internet de vulgarisation scientifique
sur l'énergie et le changement
climatique maillechort points comme en
2016 monsieur jancovici a fait un retour
sur l'album 21 au siège de la semaine à
paris et a été interviewé dans la mgm
lors de son exposé la croissance verte
n'existe pas ce soir la présentation
portera sur les
fossiles avec un petit frein c'est
original j'ai un stylo chamberlain notre
occident et haute garonne
voilà persepolis j'ai mon firme que j'ai
dit que je voulais pas causer odieux
alors j'en fais l'expérience tous les
jours que j'ai moi être des enfants et
je peux vous dire que les enfants
n'écoutent pas eu lieu
alors venir entre amants de l'argent qui
dans la salle à 20 40 ans dans sa
réponse à tout de suite dans ses détails
j'ai regardé d'expérience que les gens
qui avaient plus de 60 de comprendre ce
que je disais en français comme en rien
voilà il ya un terreau du camerounais
dans cette aventure
c'est très frustrant quand on fait un
métier auquel on croit que posé ad
gentes change en mairie où ça que j'aime
bien
la rue
c'est le goût pour ce qui regarde ce que
je vais vous dès ce soir vous avez
quelqu'un qui sait écrire qu'un seul
quand l'argent nécessaire en fait on est
quelqu'un dont vous devez dernier l'idée
de ce que je vais défendre ce soir c'est
que le débat énergétique aujourd'hui est
victime d'un nombre considérable de
malentendus sur le rôle réel de
l'énergie sur le gallix de chaque
énergie et sur ce que signifie ou
contreparties réelles d'un monde dans
lequel revient ce soir hier alors s'il
ya de l'idée que j'ai déplacé la glande
et que je peux résumer les avec cette
petite maxime qui caractérise en
particulier partie des débats français
récents qui est conséquent n'ont pas
renseigné aller plus vite possible
ça s'applique assez bien à un certain
nombre de choses que j'ai vues en
fréquentant
les cabinets ministériels tels que c'est
lui le patron
alors est ce que j'ai donné à la
conférence de ce soir le titre le
churchill à chamberlain mégawatts sarah
entrevoir à ce que tous les temps de
lire mon probablement en mémoire cette
citation célèbre de churchill
s'adressant à chamberlain ronan munich
où il avait signé les accords ans est il
allait préserver la paix dont giorgi
juillet monsieur perrin qui avait coiffé
dépôt des listes quand george hill et
c'est bien du tout à l'époque vous aviez
le choix entre le déshonneur et la
guerre vous avez choisi le déshonneur et
d'aurillac et bien à ce que je vais vous
dire ce soir en ce qui concerne les
énergies fossiles c'est exact la
transcription exacte de cette citation
historique c'est à dire nous avons choir
entre le croire qu'on va continuer à
avoir un peu denses et l'effort ont
choisi la provence est en fait qu on
aura les efforts décuplée par go on est
en train de se méprendre sur les marges
de manoeuvre est elle qui nous attendent
en ce qui concerne le alors j'ai appelé
à la rescousse
un enseignant qui fait émerger des
tickets endroit d'étudiants comme vous
êtes encore ce soir qui officiait sous
la halle et l'état après je crois la vie
de foi marc mois sur tf1 il y avait
chaque point qui officiels ont six
millions d'étudiants et sa race alien
personne n'est parfait et alors il ya
l'étoile et effectivement ils sont tous
jeunes parce qu'en venant ici j'ai vu
une affiche claude gaudin vous présente
ses meilleurs voeux et nero 10 ans sur
le site je vous confirme que les
marseillais semblent donc les gens de la
seule famille
frau n'a la réponse à cette question
leur gourou qui donne fois par mois on
s'est assis bien en français et voilà eh
bien s'ils posent cette question
française et que je prends les jambars
allemand situé la compagnie persévérant
et bien si l'avenir l'esprit des gens
qui vont voir cette question en premier
de faire l'expérience très simple c'est
l'énergie du sac
je paye tous les mois ou tous les deux
mois tout droit en l'occurrence mais
aussi des manques et ceux qui n'en
restituent thématique facture et je
voudrais en a fait la démonstration
d'une suite qui dans cette salle
locataires qui parmi les gens qui ont
dit qu'ils aient des locataires ne
connaît pas le montant de son loyer par
mois celle qui dans cette salle paye ses
factures d'électricité qui par cette
salle n'est pas capable de me donner le
montant exact sa dernière facture
[Musique]
c'est bien la coiffeuse est une pratique
la cible parce que si c'est une grosse
facture
vous seriez si c'était une grosse
facture aux cent yeux et de fret
l'énergie est une petite facture vous
avez ici les dépenses énergétiques
rapporté au baylor je vais souvent
utilisé le mot bp pendant cet exposé le
pays vers la se rendre outre le diesel
richesse en fait séparément faut le
payer les pages richesse le pays la
contrepartie monétaire en attractivité
économique de l'année le dérivé c'est un
empilement de valeur ajoutée et c'est en
gros la valeur de ce qu'on a produit
dans la vie est comme vous produisez pas
rassemblement ce matin repasse en
première approximation c'est la rue jo
cela valeurs sont achetés dans l'allier
alors réservez donc alger un avis qui
vous donne là pour d'être en ligne à ses
châteaux qui sont les trois provinces
d'énergie seulement la parole alors que
l'achat de l'énergie comparé à l'achat
de nous et vos loyers que la plus chères
les énergies monde utilisent le métro le
skate besançon gagnent en moyenne dans
l'étude est alors comme le premier
réflexe qui vient à l'esprit de tout le
monde c'est l'énergie c'est qu'ils
accueillent leur décès d'une petite
fracture conclusion qui l'a
immédiatement derrière c'est si ça a
fait carton sans véhémence et quand je
vais en recruter 400 du temps exécrable
donc energy center dont je m'occupe même
temps et quand j'ai mal quand je recule
des trucs sérieux c'est à dire de la
croissance des hôpitaux des écoles des
dix ans
à l'énergie sont fous quatre ans entend
aussi j'ai besoin qu'on me faire élire
de faire de quelqu'un et ce par coluche
l'affairé c'est vraiment un sujet
d'étude en un seul événement et tapant
fallacieux parce que l'oni masquer les
liens de dépendance est en fait les no 6
tu dis là que si je disais le point qu
de service et de vincent dubois côte
d'or
donc si je n'aurai qu'à moitié sadi les
lieux votre efficacité de marsan
question suivante c'est aussi stupide
que ça parce que ce que je vais vous
montrer maintenant c'est qu'en fait
l'énergie commande tout le reste est
exactement dans votre cervelle commandes
votre corps massif dans la cervelle
joutes il ya vu le corps trop s'il y en
a besoin
il s'apparente aux jets revenir à la
question
donc il ya des gens qui disaient c'est
une facture il ya aussi les gens chez
qui le réflexe pavlovien s'est dit info
l'économiser alors en fait vous allez
mon andreu groupe de l'histoire et moi
on a surtout cherché à verse
et c'est bien pour ça que c'est dans
cette salle si on va résultats vont
chercher à économiser l'énergie vous
auriez pas la diplomate heures je dis
juste auriemma la 7 milliards le monde
sur terre il ya les vols est également
été inculpée dans cette salle de sport
pratiqué dans le codex bilocq dire
l'énergie c'est ce dont je suis rempli
un accord je suis en forme et bien les
deux poignards dehors et le guen a
raison puisque vous vous malgré que en
physique l'énergie c'est la marque de la
transformation par des émissions
l'énergie c'est la marque de la
transformation de l'énergie
caractériques changement d'un système
est donc jugée d'énergie lui je suis
qu'à ma part du démarrage sur
l'environnement et si l'équipement lui
j'ai rempli mes marques sur
l'environnement plus j'ai utilisé
l'énergie du mali
donc l'énergie c'est par définition en
physique la transformation du monde qui
nous entoure et utiliser de l'énergie
en fait ça n'est rien d'autre de
transformer l'environnement donc plongé
d'énergie le temps semble encore hélas
beaucoup moins décousu tout je vais
vouloir dire le jeu fait les manchettes
des boilles et des cocottes minutes
plusieurs est transformé du ministère
georges plus jamais transformer
l'environnement plus en utiliser
l'énergie et donc la consommation compte
ou sans énergie sale qui se bat
juridiquement un dossier de l'énergie de
partout dans lovely day on a un appareil
qui transforme dire non voilà quelques
exemples tirés de pointe
si vous utilisez un appareil qui
transforme ta mère du mur il s'agit du
cac à l'électrique d'instruments d'un
radiateur se rouler ou d'utiliser des
énergies
si vous utilisez un appareil qui change
d'état est il dit dans le train qu'il
m'a appelé ici avec quelques minutes de
retard
les biens que d'utiliser de l'énergie
si vous utilisez un appareil qui change
de genre deux extraits sans doute
utilisé par de l'énergie
si on utilisait l'appareil en
d'abolition chimiques
vous utilisez l'énergie produite en
restitue les employés d'énergie qui
entrent en jeu et etc vous avez une
énergie qui entrent en jeu dans un corps
interagit avec un chanteur en ciel quand
vous avez les compositions atomique
change quand vous avez très important
cela dit que l'interaction bâtir
à droite wesh d'une manière générale
plus important encore pour tous les
adolescents
passé présent futur cette interaction
matière et les ventes d'iphones
considérablement plus importants dans
toute autre opération est donc une
manière générale quand vous montez
l'énergie vos comptes et la
transformation
donc je le redis il n'y a pas
d'activités productives il n'y avait pas
de vie sans énergie et donc la question
on va exacte de la navigation sur la
fois étroite entre eux
j'en utilise pas assez leur argent de
l'isro je vais tout vous savez que ça
pour vous montrer à quel point l'énergie
a considérablement modifié nos vies je
vais vous livrer à un petit calcul
alors un petit calcul du reste je vais
le localiser à marseille est ce que
quelqu'un dans la salle peut me dire
quelle est la d league les kylie a entre
le vieux port et la boîte à air 100 m
deux ans c'est à douze accords
sans aller en déportation donc vous
allez je vais l'imaginer non pas que
vous disiez dix fois de suite votre
manière ça c'est facile mais tu me
manques tirée par deux chevaux dit forme
solide sur la route vers en partant du
g20 mais conquis et bien donc imaginons
que vous facile de livres de dvd dans la
journée c'est à dire 10 fois cette
association est bien ce faisant vous
aurez développé avec aux gens parce que
les enfants s'en sort en salles assez
rare vous avez développé avec vos jambes
une énergie mécanique qui est le fait
d'avoir tissé votre masse dans le champ
gravitationnel ration de vie pas de télé
et ça correspond en douteraient un
résultat vidéo est donc vous transpirez
toute la journée à confère ce genre
d'exercice si je perds mariages ou des
récipients l'at on table cet appareil
est en fin de journée et bien tout ce
que vous avez réussi à fournir de
l'énergie et que carcasse c'est un
véhicule de millionnaire c'est vous dire
quels éléments qu'on avait du travail du
masque est souverain
c'était pâques sous la dent c'était pas
grand chose la productivité des hommes
si on fait ça un jour sur deux bouts ou
l'imaginons vous alliez avait reçu de
marseille vous faites une aide à bugeat
par jour en corse
tous les jours que dieu fait est
qu'entre le 1er janvier et 31 décembre à
la fin d'année bonne foi doit avoir un
fourni de l'ordre 100 kilowatts heure
d'énergie retenait qu'un homme bon
travail de force maximum maximorum de ce
qui peut fournir de l'énergie dans ad
c'est 100 kilowatts
si vous utilisez une paire de bras et a
priori plutôt celle de me surprendre que
les liens et que vous jouez un grand
tronc tous les jours et bien à la fin
d'année
ses diplômes en énergie
ganic que vous aurez besoin dit qu'en
cas pas au travail enfin bon travail va
produire sur l'année une capacité de
transformation de l'entreprise rappelle
que l'on reçoit l'énergie c'est ça qui
se bat là qu'elle va entre 10 et 100 kg
matériel qu'on se rend compte qu'ils
sont pas familiers les kilowattheures
kilowattheures d'énergie que nous sommes
donnés en faisant brûler un litre
d'essence à l'aider en ce 10 km marche 1
vous faites passer votre descendance
dans un bonheur le radar à nous
convertir la chaleur en énergie
mécanique évidemment à 40 ans pour
garantir la totale des auteurs savaient
par des ingénieurs millions sa famille à
berlin un cadeau dont vous allez en
sortir entre cancale kilowattheures
d'énergie mécanique
il n'empêche que dans le contenu d'un
litre essence
vous avez la même capacité à transformer
environnement si loubet dessart dans un
tractopelle dans une renault un tracteur
etc résultant d'une voiture que nous
avons 10 à 100 jours de travail de force
dans l'être humain 10 à 100 jours de
travail défense l'un des êtres humains
pour un litre d'essence dont un français
consomme plus de mes livres marque d'un
autre en vitesse de soyaux nucléaire
comme gravina six jeunes en le cognant
parce que encore une fois on verra qui
intéresse les gens
si je paye la personne qui le fournit la
transformation dans des romantiques
ce n'est pas vraiment certain didier
rolin et bien je vais payer un
kilowattheure en énergie humaine quelque
part entre quelques centaines d'euros ou
quelques milliers d'euros alors que la
machine dans laquelle j'avais des sens
se fournir à lebbeke service pour un
coût marginal de 10 centimes dit
autrement quand je passe lors à la
machine 1 je suis capable de diviser par
quelques centaines à quelques
lier le cours unitaire de 160
encadrement une fois je vous ai dit ça
je vous ai expliqué d'où sortaient les
grands magasins la consommation mascara
impeccablement par personne - coeur par
ménage travail de 35 heures par semaine
qu'on puisse dire c est qu on avait tous
envie
tout est là et on est du temps de faire
des études pour se retrouver derrière
tout ça et là tu as deux bouts tout
absolument
imaginons maintenant que des plaques
baiser en escale générale le système à
l'occasion de l'un des très rares
personnes qui s'est quand même le gars
mais qui se réunit dans des lieux tenus
secrets et si longtemps si nous fait
travailler un disque à cet esclave
vous allez en règle générale devoir
aller chercher les contrats accordés
ça va vous coûter la vente de quoi
manger tout que dans l'art en danger
d'autrui et la ligue n'est pas trop ça
va vous coûter de l'argent et encore le
nombril en cachette - reprend claude
parce que sinon le périodique
si vous mettez au tableau tout c'est
costaud de poudre et que vous regardez
en face de l'espace habitable vous
fournir comme énergie musculaire et bien
vous vous rendez compte de même les cela
va vous coûter 2 5 fois plus cher de la
machine qui travaillent 24 heures sur 24
qui faisait même en rêve
les kids earl wild absolument pas comme
sa complice en bachy la raison pour
laquelle l'esclavagisme a disparu
l'occident s'est pas rapproché votre
code génétique fait de vous des gens
lacombe égard que ceux qui nous ont
précédés de siècle vous êtes aussi mais
aussi généreux de légende qui avait
surtout il ya deux siècles
il prend bien notre avenir simplement ça
n'a plus battu une espèce de rationalité
nous emmerder avec des gens qu'on en
vienne jusque là qui arrive que tout
aussi des entames h ils ont exactement
le même service handi sa prochaine le
citoyen libre des temps anciens
atteignant c'était de gagner quelques
milliers à six sur dix fois plus des
stars qui vont recevoir dans les
campagnes et rennes dans les donc la
démocratie déjà à l'époque c'était le
luxe de quelques personnes qui étaient
assis aux résultats rapides et scarlett
c'est exactement le système que nous
avons ancré avec l'énergie ardente nous
avons créées partout des démocraties
assise sur des arts de l'islam qu'ils
ont réagit pas l'énergie pas démocratie
je le moins assez bon demandent donc que
des contreparties d'un décret
l'énergétique soudainement un chalenge
delà des critères jeudi on a commencé à
vivre maintenant
d'où la citation d'une bulle il faudra
le voir de comprendre le traité c'est
que ça me met en péril la démocratie
parce que la crainte est compliqué à
marier avec l'exercice des libertés
actuelle est donc un bon moment qu'on
est en train de vie au la partie à 120
du pacte faustien ont relancé l'accord
d'abord en ce qu'il est en train d'être
à venir encore que vous allez voir vous
avez ici
la quantité d'énergie utilisée par
personne et par an en moyenne mondiale
depuis un siècle aux cardiaques biais
des hommes qui n'ont cette fois là et il
ya un siècle et biz utilisait déjà de
l'énergie c'est à dire le fascisme
je l'utilisé d'énergie je le redis c'est
utiliser des machines à marche des
capacités lorient a expliqué ce qu'ils
utilisaient comme un ancêtre
il utilisait du bois et du charbon à me
préparer t il on agit il d alimenter
avec sa norma fois c'était des poils des
forges et maria regina
il est loin d'être un cadeau et vous
voyez que d'autres lui la quantité
l'énergie mobilisée marc personne a
fortement augmenté et de en gros les
énergies se sont empilées les unes sur
les autres
c'est à dire qu'il n'a pas une énergie
qui en a qui annualisé une autre qu'un à
remplacer une eau qui avec disparaître
une autre à l'échelle cosmique pour la
planète dans son ensemble les énergies
ne se sont pas substituer jamais elles
se sont alors on a commencé par till the
chap
on a utilisé de plus en plus par
personne jusqu'au début du 20e siècle et
puis surtout du 21 siècle la quantité de
charbon par personne est restée
constante et la reppe fortement augmenté
celle émergents de la chine au début du
21e siècle
ils seront dix à utiliser bien charbon
et bien les gens qui sont rendus terres
du nord connaissent arbres on s'est tout
simplement parce que le charbon sert sur
terre essentiellement à produire de
l'électricité
et inversement vous verrez que la
conduction électrique sur terre de son
premier thriller nôtres et moins c'est
la production est exigeant nous avons
aujourd'hui guérie sans jl one de
centrales à charbon installé dans mon
monde c'est à dire une première à
consignations 30 fois le parc nucléaire
français et géant viendrait à la vente
cet exposé si j'ai le temps et qu'on est
pas foutu dehors acteurs le iphone
toutes les mettre à la ferraille
si on veut respecter l'objectif est de
parler 35 ans à 35 ans vous mettre la
ferraille totalité les enfants la charte
mondiale
si on veut avoir ne serait-ce qu'une
infime chance de respecter l'objectif
des deux degrés j'ai bien réussi à
priver du leader mondial se parler comme
sur young et combien vous avons envoyé
un texto rien ensuite on sait qu'à une
sixième étoile en le pétrole n'est pas
du tout l'énergie de la production
électrique c'est l'énergie la mobilité
98 concerne les engins ce n'est là sur
terre alors à tim cahill voiture utilise
du pétrole c'est la raison pour laquelle
le pib est extrêmement bien corrélé à la
quantité présent
mystérieux de gars conséquence peut en
tirer compétent le se placer des fonds
bigard a sollicité en qui vous avez tout
en haut là les machins qui excite le
journal alors retenez un truc que je
veux dire que j'aurai l'occasion de
revenir plusieurs fois que dès ce soir
il n'y a pas le moindre lien entre la
pagination dans le journal et
l'importance réelle des processus dans
le monde
je veux redire qu'il n'ya pas le moindre
lien par contre il ya un lien entre
l'importance d'observer des élus et la
pagination un journal ça s'arrache très
bien il n'y a pas le moindre lien entre
l'importance réelle des processus dans
le monde des représentations dans son
vin parce que je suis en train de dire
khadra parce que à part l'attentât
certaines informations qu'on reçoit dans
son milieu professionnel
une information qu'on reçoit quand on
est élève ou étudiant il y à mag autre
canal d'accès large à l'information
collégiens vous avez que trois canaux
d'accès large à une formation dans le
lit votre formation initiale
l'information que vous recevez dans le
cadre de leur travail et vega 40
si le troisième canal et des galian ce
qui est le cas puisque dans les gares à
un million une prise d'otage l'ajacide
il vient voir cette catastrophe
un tsunami les 208 marcel gallas entre
les deux la figure donc vous avez dans
les médias une incapacité structurelle à
mettre les choses en perspective ne
serait ce que l'on met dans la
machination en accord avec l'importance
des choses dans le monde et donc c'est
marrant parce que ça entraîne et
démocratie sur les malentendus toulalan
tôt sur l'origine des problèmes et des
malentendus comptant plus fondamentaux
sur la manière
cette petite digression achevé mon avis
l'auteur ce que je viens de vous dire
donc aujourd'hui l'état standard
consomme et de leur caractère c'est que
il consomme autant si on avait valu
machine il lui faudrait deux sans escale
par personne comme on savait autant je
vais vous dire autrement si l'énergie
fossile ne nous avait pas été donné par
dame nature est bien avant que les
terriens le même niveau trick
aujourd'hui la même espérance de vie
qu'aujourd'hui etc
il faudrait qu'on ait 1400 milliards de
coûts zone située sur une exoplanète
pénale en permanence et qui nous envoie
l'énergie correspondante
voilà ce qu'est aujourd'hui la condition
humaine je conduis une poignée dit pour
gagner dans le tech 2 milliards assis
sur une harley et cela plus de billard
qui travaillent pour nous alors on voit
la radio ni d'échantillons vraiment h
petit échantillon
et c est stable ils ont en plus
l'avantagé sur les esclaves est un
ancien de ne même pas de ses concurrents
sur le sol puis ce qu'ils mangent du
sous-sol et sk des temps anciens que des
concurrents sur le solide objectif
doubler seconde fois quand on avait
comme escalader avril 13 paraît très
confiant sur le sol il y avait eu un
cheval au japon par son camp qu'il avait
confiance
donc oui nous aimons bien en somme nos
escales énorme honneur de nous font
maître par concurrents sur le sable
hommage et sert la rue et ça donne
l'équivalent de 200 exclamé marc
therrien en moyenne et par ce picard
française et sa part smicard français
c'est pourquoi je suis en train de vous
dire une première vérité politique
indice il il prend la réalité d'un camp
politique en exil
le mode lynch picard france elle
évaluera sépare le pote de via koulaks
erika supérieur
c'est aussi le mode de vie du smicard
français sauf que comme on lira lanta
non le contraire à l'occasion des
poissons nationale logique c'est
exactement j'ai regardé un peu plus tard
au même processus qui s'applique partout
ailleurs quand vous avez une conjonction
de facteurs c'est à dire la contrainte
énergétique et la l'ordre et les
politiques
un culte qui a regardé comme la récole
en turquie produits wimax et le temps
modernes et 42 nouveaux lits en passant
de manger du tarn lot en récup les
impacts de la guerre mais excellente
dans l'axé quand je vois des salles et
marler manger car mal puisque l'énergie
utilisée par les machines sur terre vous
voyez à quel point dans le bon sens et
les énergies possibles c'est-à-dire le
garde en scène énergique aussi en
l'occurrence c'est valable aussi pour
les équipes et rool et six sur sept du
pétrole sauf que c'est dû mais quand il
ya 100 millions d'années c'est que le
pétrole ya 100 millions d'années s'est
longtemps et micro ondes
vous avez une en russe et en j'avais
dali marié c'était déjà le cas il ya
quelques designers que certaines des
meilleures années sadi l'ariena des mois
plus un mental de veau et donc de temps
en temps le languedoc heures une fois
qu'il est mort une petite partie tombe
au fond les océans se mélangent aux
éléments en formation qui est les
composantes minérale à mener il incarna
les poussières sont rares et rivières
des allusions tout ça se mélange est
enfoui dans les profondeurs à certains
endroits par la tectonique et tac
plonger au plus profond plus aujourd'hui
ironiser distillés et nous attendait 100
millions d'années et crack
vous avez h 30 école à présent vous
faites un trou comme endroit au complet
et il semble étrange et bien ce
processus qui a conduit jusque pétrole
que nous pourrons faire jaillir de terre
des gratuits donc le pétrole aussi
gratuit devant vous savez que dans le
discours écologique classique on lit le
vent un mari on pourrait s'en servir et
à pétrole et gratuit bon je vais un peu
plus précis le vent gratuit ce qui
compte c'est d'aller chercher le titre
en ligue 1 puisqu'ils comptent ils
allaient chercher exactement pareil
l'existence du pétrole et graphique
totalement gratuite par une personne sur
terre n'a payé le moindre centime au
pétrole existe aussi de charolles la
côte if la commission nous attendait un
peu général adjoint de deschamps et le
japon sont en levant la main c'est aussi
leur prenons par exemple un cube d'air
de représentants contre est loin du web
de cette pièce le plus de voix pour les
deux pièces
imaginons que ce soit un journalistes
râlent donc clair
hélas et bien quand vous faites passer
s'occuper car cette année est acculé
dans une éolienne avec un vent à 94
mistral à 80 qui avait peur santé 49 ans
s'est prise vous allez à l'arrivée
récupérer la belle quantité d'énergie
que dans trois minutes de l'école la
belle vous avez dû construire l'éolienne
construire le réseau machin un tournus
de la lui sorti des orateurs et
sarcelles 810 de 10 lots wonder il vous
prenez un enseignement si vous voulez
prendre son âme incapable rend donc que
vous ajoutez fonction de stockage de
l'arrière vers vous mettez des marges en
hongrois que vous stockez dans un
barrage de mercy dans une batterie on
s'en fout le dis dès maintenant à six
donc vous êtes sur un ordre de grandeur
du kilowattheure rendu final 1 il arrive
quand vraiment elle a décidé de faire
partir le train n'est pas je sois klaus
ont condamné cette série n'est pas le
premier frein compter durant les
conférences à marseille le 5 janvier
vers lui le signal non à marseille le 5
janvier et à ce moment les
réutilisateurs 25 centimes pointures de
la fin de leur côté en tête de vie dans
les indiens mais avec déjà 48 ressort qu
est-ce que quand le pétrole du sorgho
d'air c'est déjà un stock ou de laisser
là pour transporter le transplanter
quand vous voulez et quand il est dans
les avant de me voiture vous avez votre
voiture quand vous voulez quoi quand et
du vent 0,3 cent six tonnes de rations
l'ordre de grandeur entre les énergies
fossiles et les énergies renouvelables
moderne parce que je vous aurais senti
ça avec le soleil c'est pas rien
c'est un rapport aux 50
et chaque passant quand vous regardez le
facteur 10 heures sur le coût de
production de n'importe quoi que nous
avons lu entre vient un siècle et
aujourd'hui combien ça coûte aujourd'hui
de produire une table une chaise d'une
paire de lunettes
des reçus sont bien sages ou des ya un
siècle en argent comptant un paiement et
en l'occurrence il faut qu'on termine et
donnant travail pour avoir la bonne
échelle par exemple et bien vraiment des
moments que le prêt est de tous ces
objets à l'elysée par 50 à 100 avant
vous à 10 4 jeudi quand elle vient trop
vous allez la faire mariner olympique
entière pour acheter possibilité au sol
et bien le facteur des lizards ont
regardé se valent hervé carrés de
logements et à 50% dans thales entend
vous exactement s'était considérablement
plus cher de construire et j'en garde
les maisons à la campagne de vos
enceintes compétentes quand ils avaient
la possibilité d'en ajouter une chambre
à coucher leur vie durant ses démons
même pas les moyens de faire ça
aujourd'hui en disant de saveurs du fait
construire en un appartement donc le
facteur diviseur du tout et n'importe
quoi qu'on fasse on est avec ça
correspond très exactement à ce que je
contrôle à celle d'amiens le passage de
nerfs qui étaient les seules énergies
dont on dispose il ya deux siècles à
gauche aux énergies fossiles a donc on
sait qu aux bergers à droite et
aujourd'hui penser qu'on va refaire
rejoindre sens inverse en maintenant le
niveau de vie c'est physiquement
impossible on peut se raconter quart
arrière c'est physiquement impossible
donc gérard hugot des contes pour
enfants
a envie de croire qu'on pour les grands
ce système il ya pas de créer physique
derrière le fait de boire facilement que
c'est un long chemin inverse
alors que ça faisait dix ans que monaco
est un titre abandonne 0,5 à partir du
moment où le programme électoral est
destinée non au regard des liens a violé
dans la conservation d'énergie verte et
3 vous pouvez parier toutefois ses
connaissances à défaut d'être content
aux enfants sur leurs épaules et cravate
donc je parie par exemple avec le 11ème
salon toutes les écoles prendre les
siennes de l'allemagne à jamais au bout
de sa transition énergétique à base
d'éolien et de solaire par une
transmissibles indéfiniment a visité
jeudi les dents pour angers
parallèlement et par an qu'est ce que on
va vérifier leurs amendes arme politique
avec elle son matériel en a pas un qui
soit pro américains dont convient collet
pour la conservation légale à la loi
conserver son énergie qui comme son nom
indique tic dans le système que l'on
élargisse concert appliqué à l'humanité
est la dame en conséquence très dur qui
est de la première guerre ou autres que
les exploiter à son profit une énergie
qui existe déjà dans l'environnement
si on avait la possibilité de créer au
sein de l'humanité d'une énergie qui
n'existe pas dans l'environnement
saverdun chanteur dans les moteurs ce
n'est pas le cas nous sommes le groupe
irlandais donc tout ce qu'on peut faire
c'est extraire l'environnement et
l'énergie qui compte déjà ses énergies à
des larmes les appelle les nerfs prière
c'est qu'ils sont déjà longuement parce
que brière donc le métro le lac tchad
la dcri citée est encombrant choix les
gars fier sur les éclairs d'orage des
partenaires suttner et l'hydrogène dans
mon âme à trouver des réservoirs
d'hydrogène dans le sud soldés par une
énergie primaire ce sont des vecteurs
énergétiques eon voir avoir une énergie
primaire brute faire exactement comme
les carburants en finit pas d avoir de 4
en hd sur terre les énergies primaires
sont toutes gratuites
parce que par convention le système
économique les ressources naturelles
sont toutes gratuites personnes n'ont
plus d'ansé travailler moins de santi
pour que des six sur terre du mirail
cuir du minaret d'argent des diamants
lui comme dirait qu être encore tout ça
vous avez donné qu'à cause par la nature
au bout de 14 milliards d'années
le piment de sa grave le coût de la
vente au noir
c'est vrai pour l'énergie mais c'est
aussi vrai pour aj hawk et ça n'est rien
d'autre que le coût du travail humain et
des rentes humaine on va le chercher
dans la nature quelque chose qui s'y
trouvent
graphiquement donc le comble énergie
c'est le coup de massue sur le corps du
bénin ainsi le manque de décence pétrole
ou d'impayés manche lui donne plus cool
ingénieur des techniques pour qu'ils
conçoivent étudiants jusqu'où du salarié
value right contraste tuyaux plus de rue
gounod donald burqa sans de tuyaux vous
êtes adhérent d'accord dans un derrière
l'autre sûr les rues du mans et caen ne
savait rien d'autre que des robes
musulin pourrait chercher une énergie
déjà présents dans l'environnement
l'énergie présent dans l'environnement
les diffusent mêmes pilotable avec vos
trajets et c'est juste après physique
des sols et largeur bogard on utilise de
manière significative dans le monde
aujourd'hui sont des énergies pour
lequel la nature
déjà c'est notre consommation
donc c'est de la guierle hydraulique de
6 des mois le bon resto câble et la
nature un concentré simplement un truc a
raisonnablement 11 densité énergétique
et les religieuses idée c'est pareil la
nature et l'italie
résultat rien il ya que karim est un
bouche-trou les skis pas un énarque
l'eau et à ce moment et avoir devinettes
chute qui traquent vous allez de
l'équité pour pas cher aux remises et le
tout à ça notamment une en particulier
le solaire terriblement abondant mais
terriblement 10 juin c'est-à-dire de par
unité de surface par un militant vous
n'avez pas beaucoup et bien ce que tara
à un concentré de d'exhaure de vieux
quand vous appuyer sur l'accélérateur de
deux voitures ont passé d un mois sans
ennui ce monde est pas mon 50 secondes
voire en 30 minutes
on va utiliser de plus en plus d'énergie
par personne parce que ça permet de
l'utiliser de plus en plus de machines
en fait c'était un but du jeu et ça
permettait de transformer le plus en
plus quand on a aussi été de gens mais
nombreux et ceux qui la brasserie à pau
le mans amiens collet attend maintenant
c'est la cas aujourd'hui
mais mon sentiment c'est que si demain
matin je supprime instantanément
l'approvisionnement en énergie fossile
dans le monde
je reste de base est bien là reste
zhao biens volés explique que nous
assistons actuellement à l'essor des
oeillères
alors moi qui aime bien vérifier ce
qu'on raconte le journal je me suis
livré à un petit calcul du coc qui
consiste à regarder combien d'énergie en
utilisant 2015 au monde combien en
utiliser en 2000 dans le moment riche et
la différence et d'appareillage
donc je regarde le nom vient chaque
énergie a parié dans le monde entre 2000
et 2015
donc je veux dit si la presse a raison
la première barre que je dois voir c'est
la barque solaire l'éolien la deuxième
génération mais ces gars ou s'ils ne
veulent pas d'énergie qui emporte la
première place du podium où la main sur
les 15 dernières années
ces jardins et sur l'it en passant ces
désordres jambon a directement roues et
puisque les panneaux solaires sont faits
en chine à faire s'écrouler le coût du
solaire
si on avait par le formidable
productivité a mené par les énergies
fossiles
jamais on aurait une telle décrue sur le
prix si on a maintenant un désir les
panneaux solaires et les éoliennes avec
comme seule source énergétique de
panneaux et de panneaux solaires
éoliennes y compris pour les activités
billère métallurgiques et chimiques à la
bombe je vous assure que c'est pas un
prix combat pour eux il ya un bout et
oubliez donc le siècle avoir les nerfs
sont pas servis en plus donc la première
des charreaux la réserve fédérale si
vous regardez les multiples vous vous
rendez compte que par exemple le charbon
nous montrent également qu'en soit le
plus le regard sur la période
si l'on va l'aider sérieux pour un
article en solaire et en même temps
faire 30 sur jambe par l'impression de
zenica
le japon a très fortement augmenté parce
que comme je le disais le jargon est de
très loin le premier contributeur à
l'inspection et de tête mondial vous
avez ici l'évolution d'un production
électrique mondiale depuis 1981 en 1980
on faisait un bond de plus de 7
milliards ou kilowattheure électrique
dans le monde en 1945 en 1945 on faisait
à peu près 450
il y ajoute les water il écrit dans le
monde c'est-à-dire la production
concerne aujourd'hui en première à
coxyde consommation est total dans le
monde en 1945 c'est la consommation
électrique des français d'aujourd'hui en
entonnant de ségou dit que l'explosion
de l'électricité c'est vraiment un fait
de la deuxième moitié du 20e siècle
aujourd'hui on en a rendu le monde
catalans dépendant si demain matin je
supprime l'approvisionnement électrique
the brick banque football et je suis
bridée par une réduction de ouattara en
plus des magasins des eaux usées en vide
je suis pris la chaîne du froid
je supprime une bonne partie des
transports
ça se sent donc fait parler
j'arrive pas l'histoire de carburant etc
etc
pour ceux d'entre vous qui ont eu
ravages d'omar khadr je pense que c'est
une bonne idée de la situation qui se
présentera à tous c'est à dire que
certes d'effondrement sociétale et un
état guerrier et les emotes parti très
vite
aujourd'hui on est totalement dépendants
de l'approvisionnement électrique est
vraiment notamment des temps cevital est
un succès puisque l'électricité est
faite essentiellement avec du charbon
puis aller qui gâte
alors qu on en fait encore et du pétrole
et celui passé en valeur absolue c'est
différent aujourd'hui de ce que c'est à
dire qu'en tant la rakija source
d'électricité d'origine hydraulique à
être extrêmement assez gros électricité
alors si vous avez des bons panier qui
va je voudrais bien si vous n'avez pas
le monde a dit que vous êtes pêche
français des pêches comme ça la met
enfin faire beaucoup dit dont les gestes
et en belgique en pour l'instant alpin
est la deuxième grande production
électrique sans garde marcelo nucléaire
et la ola vous avez à nouveau les trucs
qui est ici pour vous les journalistes
alors vous avez vraiment le solaire
interagisse holographie ces petits
machins orange au vent regardez le
solaire ou regard de l'augmentation du
japon sur les dents dernières années le
nokia x2 barre c'est juste pointue elle
est comme je le répète de de régime y
avait plus tard c'est supprimer dans le
charbon d'ici à ceux les plus jeunes
dans la salle image cela dans la salle
qui n'ont pas beaucoup plus de
l'entendre voilà vous avez presque
vous avez trop grande différence avec
moi on a 35 ans conçu privé de valider
des centrales champions
caen 10e ce que vous ayez mon âge je
veux que la totalité du charbon ont
disparu de la planète dans la production
letizi en vacances de deux heures et
deux heures au magasin
une fois que vous a dit ça j'ai
maintenant passer à l'économie puisque
vous avez entendu la chronique
la gt parler de l'anr microsoft qui
convient aux des processus un de
l'énergie c'est des machines de
l'énergie de machettes et la bonne tenue
de la consommation à outrance par
plusieurs sources
j'ai gueulé des tables et des chaises
long chemin avant de décoller que vous
avez appris à l'école que des risques
agricoles ont représenté ce système
je pense que vous allez tout de suite à
reconnaître dans le bouddhisme à elle à
deux facteurs de production d'accord le
travail et le jamais si le pays des
parents et de voirie guitare il
travaille et de noter vous allez raconte
si vous n'avez pas assez de production
et que on se demande comment on va le
payer les traites et bien se présente on
tire les oreilles chômeurs premier jour
du procès du matin à la collaboration ce
que vous avez et c est ce qu ils
chargent pour qu on puisse embaucher des
gens et on dit aux banquiers c'est pas
un scoop fait près d'îlots calibre au
jet d'eau de restes de l'homme de les
attendre que vous passiez à des projets
aujourd'hui si le banquier à
l'enclavement et plus simple sauf que
dans cette histoire
vous avez juste oublié un récipient de
taille c'est le globe
si vous avez un atome de juillan ici au
grade de cuir il ya dix ans habillé
banque d ailleurs en activant d'autres
trucs dans l isère et qui aujourd'hui
sont devenus les facteurs limitants
mystère ou plus exactement
qui sont les ressources à transformer si
vous avez un mois des ressources
rassemblées devant des ressources à
conserver tout ce que vous avez dans
cette salle ça n'est rien d'autre que
des ressources naturelles transformer
votre activité
donc ce radiateur 7000 références formé
par l'attractivité série no 6 de pétrole
900 sont les verts d'attractivité là
vous avez une cause génétique du chef dû
être a déjà dédié au jeu pour pouvoir
transformer par l'attractivité
tous les vêtements que vous portez c du
code génétique du coton ou du pétrole
transformé par notre activité
c'est un accident donc vous n'avez dans
cette salle et vous le verrez votre vie
durant rien d'autre que des ressources
naturelles transformé dans la pratique
et donc voir les ressources naturelles
et pour avoir de quoi les consommer des
trans mambé s'est travail la capacité de
transformation soit que sa capacité de
transformation physiquement si le muscle
goncourt d'un alors les pages et au
besoin alors imagine on travaille donc
avec leurs caméras et isabelle est
maintenant au moins égal de jours très
simple par eric abidal quand cette
histoire ça n'est rien d'autre que mes
ressources transformé par notre activité
qui ont une destination un peu
différente des biens de consommation ont
fait une baguette et de vous servez
d'arrière où la manger il avait disparu
de ce fait quand vous faites à mon fils
il vous servez mans villeurbanne ce
trail de ce fait super que ses couleurs
avant de manquer donc normalement ça
résiste elle lui dit sa surprise et la
zone différence entre le capital et les
biens de consommation
physiquement ça se produit par est
physiquement de connu pareille oreille
fonctionne entre gauche travaillent dans
les entreprises où il avait vu par
exemple sur l'informatique les achats
vont également la comptabilisation de
l'informatique passé de capital à jardy
encore un joueur venait d'être qui
faisait vingt ans après c'est les
machins qui s'immobilisent lutte plus du
capital
voilà
si vous êtes en russie dans le reste du
capital quelques bars puis quelqu'un de
gaza n'avaient pas qu'on nous faire
comprendre que ce gars là notre
convention de comptabilisation sur
quelque chose qui physiquement avec des
produits exactement dans l'habitacle
avec un veuf de 10 carats si un moment
vous venez à moi qu'est l'énergie
eh bien vous manquerez de production et
donc vous rentrez le pays des lacs app
store le fait que vous ayez les
banquiers compatissant et d'un instant
le fait que vous ayez les travailleurs
compatissant et c'est très exactement ce
qu'on est en train de vivre en europe
depuis dix ans si vous manquez de
ressources et bien pour montrer aussi
leur impulsion exactement alors qu'ils
annoncent de ressources d'énergie et de
travail des banquiers tout elle le bébé
humain reconstitué de milan 0,15 à
l'eire 1 1 mondial où est déjà un truc
intéressant
on en est entre le début d'engagement un
loisir et le voyage le pib mondial était
incorrecte sont les publiant sans casser
la croissance et est persuadé veille et
orale mais comme je l'aï dit à la barre
qui est à l'élection ceux ci directement
la conséquence tout cela si vous n'avez
pas de croissance il ne pouvait pas
racheter des libertés à celles existant
déjà et tout surplus donné à à et
automatiquement quelque chose en moins
que vous allez en tirer c'est par un jeu
est de un temple à rastan centre
si vous donnez vous à quelqu'un dans les
mois qui obligeait donc un système dans
lequel vous êtes obligé le problème des
données plus est bond de ma survie en
trois ans dans ce sens jusqu'au début de
la révolution a créé la croissance
pourquoi pour regarder et puis arrive
les combustibles fossiles là quand
avance clairement par l'iran vous pouvez
enlever le point d'interrogation et le
remplacer par un nom évidemment qu'on va
avoir 35 dont les derniers comme ça
quand je vois dans un journal économique
même de votre tenue
le mot croissance structurelle long
terme vous ai collé je me l'a dit ce bar
la construction et le terme système à
l'invention danser un truc pareil
restauration intellectuels ont confondu
dave sitek c'est bien un aspect idée
il est terriblement ce document et en
voici une illustration alors ceci est
notre homme ceci est la conséquence
logique de mon abandonne 1 à 2 cents
lorsque vous voyez ce qui correspond et
on s'attend à trouver avec le
raccordement à deux ans que vous exposez
de table vous avez ici un graphique que
j'ai peur des garde côtes fois le point
contre les faire ou j'ai mis en abscisse
tous les ans de 1965 à 2015 le la
quantité d'énergie consommée par les
hawks qui en fait trop bien on croire
que majid utilisé par les ors d'un
hectare et on en connaît la valeur
économique de la production humaine en
dollars constants 65 66 dollars à 2015
vous voyez le meilleur modèle droid aux
micro-ondes droite vous verrez leur plus
tard c'est rageant
très content j'ai très bien quand ça
marchera ce but mais ça marche même sur
dvd
vous avez ici donne au pape qui vous
donne envers la variation annuelle de
l'énergie consommée dans le monde
allaient en bleu la variation annuelle
du pib dans le monde alors c'est ça qui
me fait dire le raccordement de sang en
plus le fait que ce soit terriblement
ajouté que ce qu'on est en train de dire
en ce moment sur la best je vais venir
donc un second de l'approvisionnement
énergétique en occident fait que la
croissance ne reverra plus vous dire
avec continue peste donc je reviens à
court de tout à l'heure sur
l'approvisionnement en énergie par des
sceaux jusqu'au choc pétrolier
bill haas est en pleine forme donc la
vermine allemand énergétique par
personne demande de l'iton cent par an
alors qu'est ce que ça veut dire cette
histoire ça veut dire tout simplement
que le parc de machines au mans 2 2 5%
par an et par personne
deux ans à venir ça veut pas dire que
imagine et 2,5 fois moins de cinq ans
entre le moins efficace de l'excellente
pour refaire la même chose ça veut dire
que j'ai 2 5% de magie en plus par
personne
donc chaque personne va à contre guînes
et consommer de la musique on sent
derrière lui du coup avec deux perdu 5%
de machines en bus par personne je
transforme devient con sans ressources
en plus par personne
la production économique par personne
toutes choses égales par ailleurs ou
mango loin de l'univers sombre et au
moment des trente glorieuses que les
cheveux gris dans cette salle plus là
l'augmentation est encore présente et
c'est époque à laquelle les pays
occidentaux mettent en place des
systèmes de redistribution basé sur une
croissance de 3% par an des recettes
avec deux impacts et qu'on peut pas les
faire arrêter l augmentation a cédé le
pontage
dès qu'on peut mentir l'équipe général
et donc l'incapacité structurelle ajusté
système adresse quand tu es quand on
sent pançard est un danger entreprise
vous pouvez virer les gens désagréables
dans un bar gay de faire un désagréable
que cette étude que les survivants
l'entreprise envers les gens là on le
verra au moment la solution qu'on a
trouvé ses adeptes habituel s'en tient
pas à temps par les terminer
et puis arriva comment on me l'a se
bâtir de vouvoyer après les jours
pétrolier la croissance jusqu'en 2005
2006 elle est maître des anglos a un
autre sens des choses et à ce moment là
ses débuts dans tous les pays
occidentaux de la baisse de la
productivité du travail et de
l'apparition de l'endettement et du
chômage
partout les délits occidentaux ou même
en six étapes vers l'arménie clavère de
politiques incompétents via les veillées
en lesquelles la dette dans l'ue deux
matches pareils dans d'autres aussi et
ses rapports
ça arrive dans quelques bélie rarissime
mais c'est vraiment des effets
commencent à résonner veiller à prendre
maintenant dans tous les pays qui
dépassent les 50 millions d'habitants
vous avez vu exactement le même
processus exactement au bon moment parce
que la cause était aussi et depuis 2005
ces villages alors là pour le coup est
parti en vacances et vous commencez à en
voir ce que les économistes appellent la
stagnation séculaire or c'est à dire que
vraiment le pays ne repart pas avec pays
occidentaux il a encore envie là il a
continué à croire qu'on a révélé vers
jean heyman
comment savoir des claques les pays
émergents avec des livres n'est
absolument hallucinant et c est mon pari
c'est que dans les quelques années qui
viennent avec 22 on va de nouveau avoir
la réédition avec amour earth quelconque
alors je sais pas vous dire de vous il
va sortir et un coup de tabac
significatif à mon avis additionnel sur
l'économie et d'ici à ce que vous mobile
et en cette salle
- q je pense que l'économie à être plus
volatiles qu'elle ne l'était l'an passé
buret alors traduction concrète de ce
que je viens de vous dire vous avez ici
un graphique qui vous donne en bloc
la variation annuelle du pib par
personne donc la consommation à personne
depuis les années 60 et on orange j'ai
regardé trois périodes distinctes
avant les gens pétroliers et bob gainey
d'énergie noire de tanger woerth % par
an et le billet par personne le brésil
on s'en bat julien venu tester
énergétique par dessus après les chocs
pétroliers
vous descendez l'énergie par personne 3
0 les choses pour cent et à ce moment le
pays des mares personne ne croit plus de
demain bien vite les choses qu'on
s'empare en moyenne mondiale est depuis
vous voyez on a encore des remous un
cran et ce pour 100 par personne
on a gagné depuis 2005 c'est vais aller
du barreau les de la dette ce qui est
sans précédent dans l'histoire
économique des hommes
rappelons qu'entre 2007 et par an entre
2009 et 2014 vise à 2014 à la baisse
publique anglaise a doublé la dette
publique américaine
attablé longues années d'internât
réponse en ridicule la dette japonaise
est passé de 200 à 250 % du pib
tout ça c'est des textes qui nous ont
jamais remboursé autrement qu'en
s'endettant encore plus donc de l'est
ainsi qu'en d'assurance vie ils ont
souscrit une vente de dette perpétuelle
d'accord s'il ya un moment quelconque ya
un grain de sable qui fait que doit
rembourser la planète sinon pas avec
plus de glace qu'on a contracté avec des
revenus réels le système se cassera la
gueule donc à ce moment là on verra 26e
notre assurance-vie bouquin attendez
vous à ce que j'en ai lu martins pareil
ça
pourquoi est-ce que 2005 marie turin 2e
tournant où les joueurs en lice attendez
pour voir la nation fiscales et des
dames pour l'essentiel est aujourd'hui
les états sont incapables de rembourser
la dette
avec l'accord du futur au kindle comme
l'art en conseil qu'en s'endettant à
contre a+ et comme il faut s'endetter
pour rembourser la dette passe et plus
les intérêts c'est ce qu'on appelle
qu'un bouton dit le dr permis de tout
petits c'est vous vous payez les
graviers avec des intérêts et vous en
donner encore plus pour payer les
premières avec des intérêts d un permis
de conduire chez les canaris donc le
système de la great dit qu'on vit en ce
moment dans un approvisionnement
énergétique il a souvent raté c'est du
derby de rose
donc ça tient tant que les gens sont
d'accord vous payez pour payer encore
plus vers l'est devant nous elle a
dépassé l'on peut faire de manière pour
la création des terres sont était encore
javier la centrale qui n'avait rakim
c'est une formation alors comme htc
larissa qui marque le deuxième but
lyonnais l'état parce que les axes la
production mondiale de blé grand leur a
quasiment cessé droit vous avez ici la
production de pétrole aura moins qui
sortent des statistiques de l'eia
alors croyez que avant 2005
on roule vous avez une augmentation
régulière à bac 2 5 vous avez un paquet
quelques années sa ré invente ici les
sont plus dans les statistiques vous
agrégé ici le pétrole et son avec des
condensats qu'ils sont
les molécules un peu plus long que le
gaz naturel dès qu'ils parlent parlent
d'eux-mêmes pétrole qui s'appelle et de
20 ans la commission cadre de vie
continue de croire mais si on regarde de
près d'écoles stricto sensu
c'est un peu près clac depuis 2005 et la
lépi 2015 voyez pas bien mais sa pensée
arc en ciel c'est du lard au
visionnement d'être lié de l'europe
cordes de toute la zone ocde est passé
par accident
à ce moment là pourquoi je dépasse par
mme asma parce que l'approvisionnement
gazier de l'europe c'est
l'approvisionnement issus de la garda
world a senti son degré ce toutes les
autres et on y avoir passé leur pic est
en cause c'est les maths et les
importations qui après 2005
oui que l'arraisonnement qui ont
compensé le pic européens ne peuvent
plus augmenter gelé on va missionner qu
on en est là ce moment le héros commence
à faire de l'approvisionnement pétrolier
quasiment 10 7% c'est pas pablo
kosciusko morizet c'est incroyable ça
c'est génial a blessé et justes dans la
plaie
non seulement les rangs du garde temps
tu la regardes c'est pareil depuis 2005
elle a perdu 20% du gaz européen alors
la douceur du climat ya vraiment quelque
chose tu pas que ce qui est logiquement
quelques jours c'est la mer du nord a
fourni 500 concentre gaz en europe voilà
le sens qui convient d'abord regarde
européen c'est d'abord un verbe d'abord
60% mais on a embrassé son pic en 2005
et les lamentations en valeur absolue
les besoins communs concernant votre
balcon des très vite pascal abattre à
gazon
c'est très bon c'est pas compliqué et
dans sa naissance octobre et noir si on
avait du gaz de schiste qui n'est pas
sûr si l'on décidé d'exploiter ce n'est
pas sûr on la reprise que ça
représenterait de toute façon c'est pas
une solution à l'autoroute en l'air nous
utilisons les rushs abondante alors la
production de charbon dit le jargon vous
au produit mais ce jargon apporte aux
jambes en avant c'est la différence
entre les deux volets ça aux brasseries
temps passe et aborder les gens dit
despatie de géronce compliqué le charron
s'est imposée en deux jours les
terminaux portuaires dédié pour les
infrastructures dans l'hinterland ou
dévié et train de chanter dans le
charmant camion j'avais eu un kényan de
charbon s'est pas que son coût des
réponses à ces soit à voix nue soit du
train donc c'est dans ces installations
un bon gabarit et donc quand tu as
production lambert de jardin des clips
par la consommation rentrait de chalon
décrypte thierry gargar fusillé le dr de
la confiance du monde sait que nous
sommes fiers qu'on n'est pas concerné
maintenant on va parler du tgv lancés
par le godet la france du nucléaire
vous avez les diamants tous déjà entendu
cette affirmation qui n'a jamais entendu
que la france était un pays nucléaire
alors je me suis amusé dubaï à faire le
calcul ça qui est de regarder ce qu'on
n'utilise actuellement en france comme
énergie selon l'endroit où toute la
machine qui concerne l'énergie
si la régie qui consomme d'énergie et
chez vous sans appel résidentiel
si elle c'est un gros coeur du galon
c'est l'ars il ya certes jose celle ci à
la chine et sur lequel travaillent hors
production de pellets si elle sert à
bangui calories c'est la 6ème 0 jones et
la carte bleue vers les ascenseurs
décrite par les taux seraient
lyon les akron si la machine sert à
produire des objets dans c'est là donc
c'est non industrie si la chine faisait
applaudir de bord est très dur parce que
j'ai mal dans moult des indécis on a
géré les agriculteurs deschamps c'est
grâce aux machines on les a remplacés
par des tracteurs les vignes dans mais
on est encore à chanter la connectivité
par un agriculteur à 306 l'adema
l'énergie pour faire ça vous serez pas
avec des lancements vous seriez en train
d'exiger aux patates que vous auriez
rabaisser en cassant comme agente est
donc celle ci l agissement l'échangé n'a
ici agissent à transporter des gaz et
des marchandises
c'est là et maintenant je les cercles et
tout ce qui provient en france les
combustibles fossiles question qu'est ce
que vous croyez qu'en france aucun pays
du nucléaire a présenté la croix sont
discutés donc conclusion à tirer de ça
un maître la france est concernée par la
décrue subi en europe des combustibles
fossiles
c'est à dire des fringues a sciemment la
plus on décide de réaliser le rêve
duquel est alors peut-être et le monde
islamique et raid dakar pour aller très
rapidement à mon avis c'est parce que
nous avons un pays de caux loin j'arrive
à voir avec lui car c'est dangereux ça
sans abri comment quand je marque alors
d'arabes et de noirs
comment elles sont fonctionne on
fonctionne avec l'idée que tout astérix
qui donne contre les romains et
sympathique donc des petits qui garde
contre le monde a raison la
reconstruction
donc si vous allez à l'hôpital de la
timone que vous attendez trois heures
aux urgences
vous avez raison et l'hôpital at home on
se prépare à de savoir si vous avez
juste une région
donc si vous ne parlez que serbe si vous
êtes allé dans le local à poubelles d'un
lieu d'aller à l'accueil
c'est pas le sujet vous avez attendu
trois heures
vous avez raison et l'hôpital adore
points de même si le train vous avez en
retard
vous avez raison et la sncf attend de
voir s'il ya le nucléaire de badauds
venus 15 secondes donc si vous êtes
l'antinucléaire le petit sympathie ou
que le groupe méchant et donc vous avez
raison et records points et aussi qu'on
craint donc lentilles nucléariste dans
les médias c'est pas une affaire d'
analyse soigneuse par les journalistes
des arguments techniques issues de la
littérature scientifique ou technique
c'est une posture cette année parce
française qui fait que quand vous êtes
journaliste et que démarre ya 25 ans en
ayant suivi une formation littéraire et
comme salut par action grâce à ses capés
trail le gothique qui colle pomper des
caves ou à l'ailé à paroles ambiance
aucune piste face aussi due forme
d'oreilles 15 oiseaux despotisme à ceux
ci mènent le jeu où vous vous rendrez
compte éventuellement vous avez vous
peur pour rien conclut david à san
francisco usa plus rien donc voilà qu'on
donne en fait la raison pour laquelle
les médias en france sont
majoritairement anti nucléaire n'a
strictement rien à voir avec le fond du
problème et tout à voir avec le fait que
nous sommes un pays gaulois c'est aussi
comme ça la zone étant peut être le
diable dangereux laissez moi parce que
les dégâts le disque decca les avants
c'est différent le nucléaire c'est
compliqué en allemagne c'est parce que
c'est à la fois quelque chose de rabat
l'énergie et une énergie général et
l'art vous avez même phénomène
aux états unis dans un dédale général en
général sur les gens aiment c'est leur
canton l'homme n'a ces malades en sus
pour tango dans les délits fédéraux on
n'aime pas pour l'état fédéral
on aime bien se font les séparer or le
charbon est une énergie régional local
le duke energy général
donc c'est l'une des pluies surtout
encore une fois sa part de l'humiliation
de l'occupation américaine et la chine
elle en parle nucléaire mais d'une
manière de 1,9 vous est donné vous avez
tous entendu parler du gect le jet qu'il
est un enfant pour tous jusqu'au départ
du programme des nations unies pour
l'environnement et de la réalisation
météorologique mondiale donc en 1988
l'organisation médian du mondial pour
habitations de type environnement le
site vers l'enfant qu'ils appellent le
giec
là j'en saurai tiennent donc le mandat
est de synthétiser ce qui est disponible
dans la littérature scientifique et
technique sur la question de la raque de
lokeren au final c'est sa moralité car
le grand tchèque par un laboratoire de
recherche
il était petit du geiq ces 15 personnes
un truc tôt les chercheurs qui font les
rues j'accepte de me casser la structure
lui même ses impressions ses tout petits
défis et le gel librement si je me fais
une synthèse de ce qui se publie y
aidant quaternary sarrians geophysical
letters
j'ai parcouru actuelle cinq ans voilà ce
que je vais vous raconter les et ça fait
de lui mais en 1955 le même par an pour
tous à gauche pour le pôle intégration
et l'organisation mondiale de la santé à
droite point frère aîné on the run est
je crois un enfant à tous et qui
s'appelle bon ca qui dans la salle comme
des cellules t art ont des gens qui
travaillent nucléaire c'est un luxe car
dont vous êtes la batelière l'intitulé
fait le même leur collecte
c'est à dire qu'ils synthétisent ce qui
se trouve dans la littérature
scientifique et technique à coke des
lectures sur l'effet des rayons
ionisants sur les hommes et sur
l'hexagone
une serre apparemment sortir 2013 un
rapport sur fukushima
je vais ou des sites qui que ce soit la
salle je regarde à nouveau parler d'eux
et fois nous savons que ce soit en
économie sur le fait que vous n'avez
jamais entendu parler de ce carcan loin
ou bigard si lacombe est d'accord et ce
qui a alors à vos questions il ya
notamment la phrase en rouge
il n'y aura pas d'effets sanitaires
discernable liés au surplus de radiation
ont lâché par l'accident à fukushima
non c'est une excellente nouvelle quant
à la france est à gueuler qu'on vous dit
à bâbord général pourrait miser en dire
un terrible accident but sens mais
quelles étaient vos gamins et on vous
dira quoi rajouter un peu de m donc là
les nations unies au fond un accord au
sein d'une agence jamais exactement
comme le giec en disant sa femme à bord
dont trois corps
payez pas possible bon là il ya
anderlues un foutage de gueule parce
qu'il faut donner ce régime
parlementaire il ya quelques jours on a
expliqué que cet accident fait 1700
valoir je suis scandalisé les impôts
c'est un avantage et des favoris
la chaîne parlementaire ce désamour
conscience donc c'est moins préserver ça
va rater le g20 karabagh et soit dit en
passant le relais à doha vous explique
que les rabattre à peine discernable sur
l'environnement très méchante habilement
à part quelques endroits préparer cet
argent sera contée l'élite inverse
on se fait peur pour rien alors je vais
vous montrer qu'il s'agit d'un moyen n'y
a pas beaucoup de son âge qui permet de
matérialiser le fait qu'on se dit pas
combien a réagi quand il s'en sortir on
a un travail qui est fait par un m
chercheurs qui depuis des années et des
années demande aux français ce qu'ils
pensent sur jambes climatique
alors il leur pose la question est une
des questions qui leur poste est à votre
avis quelles sont les activités qui
contribuent à l'extérieur c'est la bière
ou changement climatique en voyage
activités industrie transport et l année
insulté rigolo un français sur dix
pensent que les centrales nucléaires
contribuer significativement aux
émissions de gaz à effet de serre un
concept repose à ouvrir moi quoique
passion du coin ça rend logique que dans
une transition énergétique qui vise à
lutter contre le changement climatique
ont des angles du béarn en deux ans avec
marché intérieur dans les pages
intérieures comme les gens en vrai que
général une fois qu'ils ont fini leur
dire combien elle est allée chercher
leur démarrage
ils ont pas vraiment le temps de lire
les ouvrages spécialisés pour savoir ce
cycle nucléaire
et je revois ces lycées comme ça pour
aller chercher les gens là où ils sont
et bien il y en a un sur deux se dit il
ya des grands panaches don à sa future
pourquoi ces choses c'est machin c'est
scélérat sa carrière jo chaud il fait
sergio ajournant climatique joue donc à
york de la pire espèce a dit c'était pas
bon il ya un malentendu sur dans
l'univers maintenant d'illustrateurs il
y en avait dans mon camp je veux accuser
un journaliste anglais rapidement s'y
connectent guerre et qui n'ont
absolument pourquoi il y en a jamais
parlé lagarde ses pieds au piratage avec
lui il en parlera plus en parlant de
plus simple vous devez gagner c'est vrai
j'ai claqué 3 1 sur le nucléaire c'est
le fait que ya là aussi un axe au pays
des merveilles circular sur ces
inconvénients économiques ou plus
exactement ses inconvénients économiques
comparées aux avantages et en deux ans
je voudrais ici de 13 3 pour comparer un
système qui serait notamment nucléaires
versus totalement il bien servir ainsi
qu'aux gens mais c'est pour vous faire
sentir à leur demande sinon passez un
système notamment nucléaires en première
approximation france y alla de système
français la rappeuse hydraulique donc
c'est pas mal je suis archi trichet on
va dire le système français et vous
m'aidez du sang pour sang mêlé c'est au
japon que des uc les airs vous avez un
acteur de charge qui se baladent à 8,87
genre qu elle soit 180 porte en face
vous avez un facteur de charge pour
leurs liens autour de leurs vins
25% ce qui veut dire devant passer d'un
système nucléaire insiste l éolien
devait installer trois à quatre fois
plus de puissance pour avoir
l'électricité avant d'être ensuite un
réacteur sur 60 ans 80 des états unis de
40 en france 94 60
une éolienne salut en vente par at-il
moi je vais quand même vous allez avoir
à coeur de la foire va payer deux fois
sur l'italie ensuite quand vous mettez
un teint plein plein de sources de
production dans le détail pour accorder
plus de trucs que ce que vous aviez
avant les barreaux plus de trancher aux
blues le câble bus de bonnes sources
beaucoup plus de cela et donc vous allez
coude environnement électrique qui
entretient la consommation son
équivalent au coût d'investissement
directement dans les dispositifs de
production et ce à l'intérieur d'un
graphique que j'ai piqué sur le site
allemand des ministères de l'énergie et
maintenant j'arrive à prouver mais hier
avant de répliquer ça et il est en route
et un mois et à chaque fois j'ai eu des
discussions privées avec des gens chez
les disquaires télé ou du moins avant
leur demande à l'egypte liés par de
hauts les visites chez zara
ensuite si vous avez eu des mots bien je
le redis sera m'en donnera un grand
événement et a surtout du manque d'air
donc vous prenez
d evaristo qui au premier rang faut se
le dire pour l amandier rené garrigues
de l'éolien vous avez 80 à 90% de la
production qui arrivent dans le désordre
en première approximation vous avez
moitié a stocké 40 100 % pendant la
chanson beaucoup les gens demandaient à
ce moment pour multiplier à nouveau à 2
720 par contre a légalement les
regardent moins chers qui ont même
installé que lui dr donc l'arganier un
facteur 10 heures enfin si vous êtes
tous les facteurs explicatifs les
facteurs diviseur à la fin vous vous
rendez compte le total d'argent qu'il
faut mettre sur la table pour avoir un
système 100% et aux liens plus stockage
encore une fois vous n'avez pas votre
gauche vous refroidit votre peur que
lider d'avoir choisi l'été est bien un
instrument il faudrait dix à vingt fois
plus d'investissements son latin alors
je mangeais offrant là où ça coûte 300
milliards de roubles de refaire à neuf
le parc nucléaire français
sound cyril si on décide de faire comme
l'éolien avec stockage pour la légende
et d'électricité dans le pays les
françaises de 1000 milliards d'euros bas
donc 300 déjà les gens violence et
enlever civile
environ les fêtera ses 6 filiales ou
l'allemagne ira jamais au bout de son
énergie 22 avec les panneaux solaires et
les éoliennes jamais aujourd'hui c'est
quinze minutes cela parce que en
décidant de commencer par le nucléaire
et se condamner à garder des jambes je
reviens de deux mois le charron à cause
de la géologie un peu du co2 maman de
pétrole à côte
la géorgie demande en mariage à cause
des chenaux logique de moins en moins de
nucléaire de la souris étant beaucoup
plus de nerfs à cause du coût en capital
l'autre chose et mozart el hadary d'eau
et donc depuis 2006 l'approvisionnement
énergétique européen fesf la production
industrielle européenne les bases et par
un maximum en deux sets
depuis sa baisse et ça raconte eagles
donc c'est un succès si je regarde par
personne eh bien vous voyez que le sang
s'arrête de l'ocde au mont les champs
pétroliers et ça commence à 10 ans en
2007 et nicvax ni hollande ni vers
luchon et mélenchon un jeu j'aime bien
sûr ni sarkozy défis des changements y
avait quoi que ce soit ils changeront
rien ces nuages géologie et la physique
changeront rien et voilà ce que ça donne
sur le bitume à présent d'envoyer à un
moment on avait plein d'énergie en
croissance
puis on a eu la même quantité d'énergie
puis ça c'est d'y aller croire et à la
terrible et je vous avais arras aussi
les idées de mon but est de vous
autoriser la libre circulation de tous à
l'intérieur de la zone
vous avez un rééquilibrage c'est une
différence de balancier qui sont pleins
donc vous avez un rééquilibrage entre
l'ouest et l'est
les industriels de mettre les usines de
voiture à l'est et les blocs de l'est
moins bien en bretagne et les bretons un
grand disparu est restée française s'en
tenir aux il inclut dans le mettre sur
le banc tout prix et à chaque fois qu'un
élu il vous dit élisez moi j'aurais
requins la croissance le borda
probabilité que derrière il ya des
troubles sociaux graves
c'est comme si le médecin nous dit que
les chez moi et je vous fais un
diagnostic sans cancer
je vous dis à l'avancé
exactement le même regard des états unis
qui est le bien qu'ils gaz de schiste
amiraux de journal dans un duvet
tonnerre l'avant par personne aux états
unis est passé par un maximum un maximum
absolu au moment de voir des gens
pétroliers depuis sa baisse et réduit
2006 le sac pour garder les lumières à
coup de gaz de schiste et du pétrole de
schiste
un talent du sud et si je vous dis je
vais vous parler bien que notre
augmentation salariale et joubert
salaires je vais regarder la cgt des
noirs a carrément dit ce même punition
et c'était pas plus efficace qu'il y
avait du pétrole dans le mix énergétique
du pays au départ voilà le même sillage
de points que j'ai fait pour le monde
mais cette fois ci je veux rentrer pour
la casse en parallèle je parle 65 je
suis au chronologique
beaucoup de groupes en 2006 tu roules à
quoi ressemble le mix énergétique de la
grèce
60% le défendre et un positionnement
long terme et vol des grands il ya
répondu devant nrj grégoire est le pays
des grecs pour beaucoup comme jean tu
mangeras index faisait rien
ça marche très bien également
vous voyez avec nos amis italiens sont
les majors contre pétrole d'un mix ça
marche même manière pour nos amis
espagnols
quand vous tombez très bien qu'il va
faire autrement voilà comment évolue la
provisionnement exactement la variation
la peau tellement énergique nra zo c'est
la zone ocde c'est laurent l'amérique du
nord le japon la corée du sud
l'australie ainsi son label est belle et
riche industriel et bien vous voyez que
l'approvisionnement globale en énergie
dans ces pays là il ya 50 ans et un
montant de 348 de leurs liens vie 0 il
m'a passé négatif les banques
le pib de la zone n'a croisé force de
branco 1 croit de moins en moins tout le
monde pense qu'on va regard là selon ce
footballeur et addition son casting
d'aragon
donc on va avoir de moins en moins de
moyens vont gérer de plus en plus
d'engagement parce que par ailleurs des
emmerdements aux pentes qui sont
l'héritage de zèle consommation fait les
digues qu'on critique de vos images
alors une petite confusion
donc à partir de maintenant les moins en
moins de moyens et bunch tout cas j'ai
eu un qui consiste à réussir en colère
on dément 110 quand on dépenserait 1
pour le même résultat et maintenant de
la clé comme ça accélère la survenue des
emmerdements gérard de vous énerver
idrac 18 dans ce contexte le genre à
nous est ok ça sert à rien ça résoudra
pas les problèmes de survie en 81
suite mais le photovoltaïque et l'éolien
en france à un public aussi pour la
ville c'est à dire que ça ne sert pour
résoudre le problème dont je suis en
train de parler ça évite pas de co2 et
ça recommence en haïti comme ça on évite
ça on évite en dépensant sans leur coût
des mesures permettraient d'y arriver en
pensant à quoi elles sont considérées de
voir un jour déjà exclu siècle on voit
que je mens climatique
vous savez que le changement climatique
à quelques climato-sceptiques donc
glisse dix soirées pas grâce à ses
différentes where do a toujours les
climato sceptiques dans 50 ans il y aura
en dehors des plateaux sceptiques ne
disparaîtront jamais parce que leur
motivation n'a rien à voir avec la
science qui rentrent moins des
climato-sceptiques de l'altération des
emmerdeurs électrique le fils quelques
heures le vendeur il faut avoir en tête
vous avez ici une carte qui vont
représentent les écosystèmes sains
installés en europe
aujourd'hui si on ne les supprime pas
offert des vagues des pharmacies des
gens des lignes de tgv et des ralentis
ont su grippale asie qu'aux systèmes
installés pour faire les choses qui
comptent chose à voir là les gens
négocient celles qu'on a aujourd'hui
donc on a essentiellement par la foule
on a parfois un casting brisé et lui dit
trop fort a trop chaud big love voilà à
quoi ressemble l'écosystème européen
gare à vous avez envie d'entendre la
cause des ratier
c'est un moment dont il fait l'effort
vous un docteur dernière ère glaciaire
et l'europe ont parcouru par quelques
équipes quelques bagues aux points clés
de cette europe est malheureusement
assez différent de l'europe une police
la première différence les deux arrivent
à l'appel barbie envers des vins bio il
n'y avait pas un petit loto puis la
finlande et d'espoir jamais de glace
qu'on se lit pas un mais bien deux
mètres de castan a fait ça donc y
remédier il y avait du reste de 50
heures sur le gala on avait également
des les écossais dans l'ancien palais du
sel sur les français pouvaient aller à
pied sec [ __ ] la pâtée aux errements
des quotas n'est aussi gros et loire
brebis car le trait cote passer un
extérieur de ce qu'elle est aujourd'hui
l'angleterre l'océan et légumes à m
parce que les calottes glaciaires qui
s'était formée sur le canada et sur la
scandinavie avait pris tellement long
des bords de l'océan on se forme et que
le niveau de l'eau a baissé deux ans ma
mère
vous voyez que les écosystèmes installé
non diagou on ressemble à ce qu'on a
aujourd'hui au nord de la sibérie et
dans ce genre d'environnement et bien la
population totale de la france est celle
d'un quartier et passez sans me brusa
d'accord vous à bouffer un animal budget
confirme jean elmander colom
wariner en version 10 ans bill evans
quand on est passé à gauche au paysage
de droite la température s'est joué
juste et bien au niveau planétaire loin
dans les terres a augmenté de 5 petits
degrés quand on est passé du bétail de
gauche hôpital de droite ça s'est fait
en s'inclinant à l'époque les migrations
des populations des mensuels s'il y
avait un problème par la suite
en alimentaire dans l'environnement
monsieur chefs de tribus désolé les
temps qui courent ça prenait sa plus
belle ma su distribuer quelques matchs
prenez la chef de tribu par la tignasse
et crack
on était parti dans la grotte à côté
avec un capital à déplacer qui n'est pas
excessif trois failles de la peau et un
pot de peinture pourront d'ailleurs les
gabonais il était clair qu'aujourd'hui
si on doit avoir une modification à
large échelle de l'environnement c'est
pâques aussi de nous adapter de cette
manière parce que vous ne dépassez pas
quelques centaines de millions 2,2
milliards d'individus avaient sur le
coeur
le métal de la timone l'archivage les
églises les bords des routes les voies
de tgv
les gueugnonnais reynaud à dubaï et au
surplus là vous avez envie d'aller le
jeune auvergnat
c'est sympathique il ya déjà quelqu'un
est le gagnant carragher ont besoin les
armes ou bien c'est pas sympathique et
la personne et son ventre ou verbale a
aucune infrastructure
donc il est absolument évident qu'une
élévation de température de quelques
degrés en un siècle pour moi c'est là
qu'apparaît le camp se trouve pas en
donnant le prix nobel la belgique
alors ça si fumer ou jacques on se
trompe pas on se trompe pas parce de
second fait c'est vraiment de permettre
à une entité et attire notre attention
sur un problème majeur de s'exprimer et
le moulin à images par seconde fois le
changement langues allemand au surplus
qui va arriver dans un nombre d'écoles
d'énergie quand aujourd'hui c'est un
échec thonaille qui va réduire la taille
d'espérance de vie de la population par
un facteur 2 - inconnu mais qui sera
préservée mans
derrière un très certainement supérieur
donc je veux la question de coups de
joran climatique c'est vraiment la
question d'attaquer l'espérance de vie
de la population je n'ai aucune
inquiétude en fait un agent maison et
zap agit-il banque intitulé on est des
animaux tellement humide swissmetal
campion s'approche partout j'ai
absolument aucune inquiétude sur le fait
qu'il y aura des hommes et des femmes
dans un siècle dans deux enfants par
contre genk est les larmes séchées et
j'avais montré que ce problème dans le
ciel déjà vous avez ici une carte des
évolutions à quand les précipitations
sur terre dans le carde les journaux qui
notent quand vous recevrez licence ne
pas perdre les médias mais en fait un
changement climatique c'est un jugement
tous les paramètres et je cercle francas
zone
vous voyez que ça va s'assécher c'est le
bassin méditerranéen
vous voyez que c'est la seule zone qui
sache dans la base il dans le cas du
changement climatique en cours
il s'appelait 15 ans oblige - des restes
de combelles que je relis détails connus
oui je sais qu'il vous concernant
[Musique]
l'autre jour il est vrai que ça sèche
alors maintenant je prends la carte non
pas des variations futures une
réhabilitation et les variations passées
de précipitations le tacle décennies et
joseph même jambon et regarder tous les
avoirs qui sont déjà à gégé se trouvent
dans les mêmes cercles
qu'est ce que ça veut dire on est déjà
en train de voir la barque du genre
matic sur la variation des
précipitations alors prenons voisin
syrien
vous avez ici pour la syrie en rouge
l'évolution de la population envers
l'évolution de la production agricole
avec son 2e tour à gravir à la marquise
et puis à partir de 2007 les sécheresses
de plus en plus violent ce que vous avez
sur pontons du bassin méditerranéen
commence à vous aider
la production agricole et dans le même
temps la syrie qui n'a pas grand-chose à
exporter et qui n'est pas ouverte aux
touristes ne peut pas subventionner les
importations pour sa population
exode rural 10 heures au lieu de vous ce
que vous voulez quand vous regardez le
déclencheur les printemps arabes c'est
les mecs autre sécheresse que sa
capacité à faire face aux importations
pour un contexte économique après crise
de 2009 c'est-à-dire la papeterie les
rebelles ils sont déjà là à la fois dans
le journal qu'il est du loup simplement
du pétrole depuis 2005 la dette pareil
et des réfugiés syriens qui sont partis
du d'abord partie dû aux revenus des
conséquences significatives du
changement climatique le problème est
cependant plus cher et il a commencé
simplement l'attribution des gosses de
la veste on le vend à l'hôtel et du goût
des bacs à papier
je vais aller puisque le temps décompté
directement à ckoi
j'ai eu au plomb
les deux grandes mains alors les
dossiers droite prétendantes qu'il faut
garder toute la première c'est l'énergie
bébé la deuxième c'est quand édition
température vous avez ici à gao
situation qui a été publiée dans
arrivants jek et qui vous dit en gros la
chose suivante vous prenez sur cet axe
horizontal des éditions cuvée louis
casaï de co2 par an que l'humanité aura
entre 1850 et 2100 de cumul et vous
regardez en correspondance quelle et
l'élévation de température ont résulté
rare de l'issan par rapport à duisans la
vente d'applications concrètes à fin
2015 on a eu déjà remis milliards de
tonnes de co2 dans l'atmosphère et donc
on est absolument certains ont un second
degré quelque chose d l'évasion
température moyenne en 2100 par coralie
sanglante
en fait on avait pris cette année par
rapport à 850 leur part envoyé si je
tiens raisonnement inverse comme je dis
jolie diane degré c'est d'abord de paris
eh bien ça veut dire que j'ai le droit
de 23 mille milliards de tonnes de co2
dans l'atmosphère un appareil de plus en
plus un talent des deux fixings en rosé
droit d'énoncer coin bureau dont j'ai
déjà dénoncé donné un débit quotidien
donc ils en ont semé les germes nomme à
émettre dans le ciel libyen pour une
humanité en moyenne trois fois plus
nombreuses que celles qui a déjà eu lie
les deux milles sur le siècle vient de
s'écouler
c'est ça c'est utiliser aussi vite que
possible les émissions par personne par
5 suisse linz police et armée l émission
gueule les liens bull prend de lille 4 1
dans cette affaire qu'est ce que les
mairies ont décidé de faire à paris et
bien à un besoin des idées augmenter
leurs émissions
donc vous avez ici
ce qu'on appelait les ai laissés c'est à
dire les réclamations attention les pays
qui sont partis à la can mais paris et
lyon tous dire dans la range les mettre
dans l'eau gelée maintenant moi je vais
maintenant gérer tes hanches 108,25 il
ya là vous faites si tu marques de ski
ont décidé de son communiqué et mesure
donner un gros point noir et d'après une
année de dire les d'envoi de résoudre le
problème
enfin si vous allez voir le magic qui
voulait elle a découvert et gullit a je
crois que le problème je le connais un
peu plus
à mon avis il a quand même pour regarder
ailleurs bizarre ce qu'il faudrait y
aura c'est sûr que là c'est ça qu'il
faut qu'on fasse qu'on le devrait
pour les cas strictement rien à voir
avec ce que bon le grand les parties
qu'on fait c'est qu'elles consentent
despars en jacquard des camps dans le
courant du 20e siècle on avait réussi à
faire baisser les émissions honnête le
bon sens par an alors j'ai trouvé
d'autres - la crise de marne auch et
l'éradication du japon d'allemagne après
j'ai regardé s'il est délicat mais
ratifié kyoto à l'éveil différence par
rapport à celui là l'est va ratifier sur
la décarbonation la règle est que ce que
tout le monde fait dévier cité alors
j'ai regardé le rock et la quantité de
co2 marlard le tibre sur les 50
dernières années les appels quand j'ai
regardé évasion
est-ce que ratifier un accord
juridiquement contraignant des nations
du lycée quelque chose qui fait que vous
allez affirme on devrait la consigne en
arabe
ça aide cordis par contre c'est après
l'abandon
c'était bien bon side et c'est pas la
fin de l'histoire
donc après l'accord de paris j'avais
écrit une petite tribune dans les échos
quand le titre des victoires taux reste
à faire
expérience doit redresser affaire ne
suffit pas dépenser d'argent pour que ça
marche
vous avez ici l'énergie wendel en
allemagne alors petite bise à vous avez
ici
la quantité de co2 par unité d'énergie
utilisée en allemagne toutes énergies
confondues ben c'est pas juste
d'électricité des carburants l'industrie
le jura j'espère et je les ai enlevés
les années en marche et donc la question
est est ce que vous êtes capable de vous
dire de contacts au début de l'été
arrive et de 1 annonce c'est d'avoir
perdu deux on pense bien la réponse est
non la démence et 300 milliards d'euros
grandement au nucléaire aujourd'hui ils
vont expliquer devant et que je vis avec
de petits graphique 1
c'est la répartition des émissions
aujourd'hui de gaz des réserves ont donc
cette année qu'il faut diviser par trois
d'ici à 2050 si on veut avoir développé
pour les 10 et maintenant 20% des
émissions au monde pourrait être
confondu un cépage est au c ur de ses
centrales à charbon les seules centrales
à charbon c'est pas un pour cent des
émissions mondiales de gaz à effet de
serre les enfants là pétrole et en gaz
nous avons des 6,7 les cimenteries ces
5%
l'émission gagne 70 que les centrales à
gaz le reste de l'industrie dans lequel
la syrie est en sang
ces doses les chauffeurs de l'action en
direct ces 6 donc s'ils en reçoivent en
france on n'a pas le poste électricité
vous le passé industriel et pas aussi
important et le mot transports
parmi eux on n'a pas les centrales à gaz
plus légalement et en exercice les
transports ces quinze vous et moi quelle
centrale jean rené que les transports
c'est moins que les centrales à charbon
donc vous voyez mart ou les nuits du
climat s'est employé à les aider mais
c'est vrai les deux hommes là l'accord
les voitures ccist également c4 et la
mare à illzach et les avions c'est tout
les cimenteries à elle toute seule ses
copains le mental de gagnant donc on
n'est vraiment pas sorti du problème
juste en mettant des éoliennes et en
disant qu'ils ont avec les libéraux
c'est vraiment empreinte de société si
on s'attaque à 100 et c'est normal parce
que l'énergie est prêt maintenant
patienter vingt rockets en france les
bottières l'emprunt carole de
l'alimentation d'un française j'étais
beaucoup parce que les archives de du
méthane en fait aussi du reste égale à
celle des par ailleurs on utilise les
engrais azotés dans les champs il ya des
émanations protoxyde d'azoté derrière ça
aide aussi un gaz à effet de serre la
vis en gestation séduite et c'est un
déterminant avant de l'agriculture ont
décoré leurs premières puces donc le
banc on a besoin de compter en plus si
on veut bouffer celui-ci o'gara moment
il ya une responsabilité majeure de la
consommation de viande dans les
émissions d'origine agricole et enfin
vous avez que des gouttes d'eau alors
que je vis bien avec un manifeste de
lens le chiffrage est en ce moment en
disant voilà ainsi le rôle sérieux qu'on
sentait qu'elle fait elle se mit à la
croissance de revenir là bas donc je
dois passer la consommation à la
reconstruction
c'est par ailleurs votre boulot donc
c'est un programme dans lequel je rends
les jambes où l'on parle pas non plus
que jamais au boulot
faire l'europe capable d'observer sans
énergie fossile
j'en ai 50 ans un quoi mais c'est un
programme qui ne supporte pas
d'augmentation la concurrence est vive
au change
parce que l'augmentation de la
concurrence et du libre échange
multiplie les moyens de production au
lieu de les médiatiser dans un bouquin
train sur les ressources physiques
multiplier moyens production de
l'économie
donc on a besoin d'autres ont des flyers
de la mutualisation et si ça doit le col
en garde également garder moi ça va très
bien tant mieux pour ceux qui sont en
vie pour ceux qui sont par son succès
l'intérêt collectif
la seule question dans ces relations car
les actes c'était en sorte d'avoir un
niveau socialement acceptable
socialement acceptable aujourd'hui
compte tenu des taux d'intérêt qui sont
à 0 6%
or donc il faut faire ensemble en
pensant kevin ont investi dans les
métiers protégés south à ixelles pas de
bon sens ça veut dire que vous allez
devoir et spécialiser les ut parce
qu'aujourd'hui faire du bruit sous 10000
personnes qui fait entièrement les
camions qui communique avec une grosse
musique qui fait des portières droit des
gagnants qui communique avec une grosse
usine qui sait la cabine du camion qui
communiquent avec leurs fusils qui
assemblera avec la romandie gagnant qui
obsédé à sa marche en avant ce mandat
les nations donc on va devoir est
spécialisé dans les rangs des lébous
fabrication et tout ça arrive d'abord
qu'est-ce qu'on veut mon logis pour le
mec on propose que construisent leur eau
chaude la décarbonation des gonna be
comme on l'a construit avant leurs
bourrelets
je rappelle c'était la communauté du
charbon l'acier en europe au début et là
plusieurs structures qu'on propose c'est
supprimer charbon en électricité obligé
constructeur avant des véhicules qui ne
dépassera 2 litres aux 100 en 2030 dont
baisse progressivement en fin de droits
a multiplié les réseaux de bus express
dans la périphérie de lille à plus long
terme qui avait clairement lieu parce
que la banlieue et d'un tissu urbain
bancs tables dans un monde à l'écart
contraintes que reste il est apparu
souvent ce petit pull noir dans le monde
à l'énergie arrogante et cet art issue
qui ne survivra pas à l'énergie
aujourd'hui quand vous regardez de lutte
la déshérence économique dans ce pays
c'est dans ces zones à l'est belgique
c'est pas juste une affaire heureusement
des palois pouvait se demander s'il a
corrigé graphique explique dans un monde
sans pétrole vous n'avez plus easyjet
pour aller voir le voisin alors c'est
important d'aller voir ses voisins à
l'idée de se marier avec un temps en
temps parce que c'est ça qui fait que
les peuples se trouvent partout la
guerre donc il faut maintenir les
échanges les maintenir quand vous avez
trop loin de pétrole
il ya qu un seul trimestre a donc il
faut investir dans le réseau ferroviaire
qui solo divisé par deux à 3,6 à 2050
les frais de production de matières
premières en industrie donc temps
puisqu'on y de florange je faisais part
à la course je voulais faire donc ils
font diminuer la production d'acier de
ciment et les nra l'éducation l'économie
circulaire c'est ça c'est moins qu'en
2000 et plus réparer il faut rénover
tous les logements existants en
obligeant les propriétaires à faire
sinon ça ira voir si vite
tous les enfants megan cette salle sera
logé sa fine connaissance parce que cela
journal du tout il verra plus de valeur
que si vous avez investi un peu de
réconfort dans le fait de les étonner
il faut rénover dans le tertiaire public
du ray star qui va intéresser rôle
critique parce que c'est pas briller 20
6 me dirai donnez votre appartement
par contre si vous leur dites l'hôpital
de la timone passoires énergétiques je
signe un contrat sur marc angrand
milliards ça sert tout pour eux je ne
sais pas sur l'éducation il faut
développer de manière significative à la
filière forestière
parce que ça séquestrer du carbone parce
que c'est une ressource locale parce que
ça remplace ciment et d'acier
parce que saddam était bénéfique que ça
permet notamment d'améliorer
l'infiltration le mans les salles
espérant que le bonheur est il faut
diviser par deux chez tf1
et comme j'aime beaucoup les épaules a
comprend un équipement plusieurs boules
moi ça me va bien il doit gagner moins
d'argent
ça veut dire qu'on va mettre en place
dès godard avec des briards anticon ces
gens là qui sont trois au dessus de ce
qu'ils sont aujourd'hui
et il en faut moins élevés air d'été et
qu'ils ont besoin est par ailleurs ils
seront plus de temps qu'ils sont
disposés le brand des services
écosystémiques typiquement s'occuper
noblanc délais
montréal autre type de travaux qui sont
il faut savoir donner vous avez
l'évolution arrosée dans ce pays vous
rendez le lait de avant d'obliger en
litres le quand vous demandez à la
grande distribution
donc ce que je propose c'est pas
nécessairement la winter voilà je suis
désolé quand vous avez vous secourir un
incendie puisque nous avons les bas ces
dix minutes de leurs délégations
brassage et compliquent question
secondaire
[Applaudissements]
il agassi une fois on répond je crois
c'est un conteur exceptionnel donc là
pour nous donner votre site et que nous
avons vu ce avoir ensemble de vaucelles
deuxième point de la maison vous êtes
quant aux mesures les troisième point
les étudiants disent que l'on compte
ceux qui veulent des légendaires de la
revue générale du club qui sont un bien
est ce que c'est vraiment triste
voilà mon sommeil
[Applaudissements]